dicker ich habe irgendwie musik drauf
von irgendwo hast du das einfach wurden
ja hast du das gemacht was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video
da hatte ich hoffe es natürlich geht es
gut heute eigentlich sollte es
eigentlich sollte dieses video schon
längst raus gekommen sein
ich habe dann allerdings hier tgr
portion kirche airport in
anführungsstrichen und dazwischen
genommen das paket liegt hier schon eine
weile rung kam zusammen mit den bi 200
tws an einer airport kopie aus china
denke ich mal
zumindest kommt das immer von
chinesischen herstellern und ich habe
von ganz ganz vielen zuschauern also von
euch bei instagram nachricht bekommen
dass ich auf jeden fall mal diese
airport des kopie testen muss wir haben
hier die 1000 tws kopie der zweiten
generation airport übrigens habe ich gar
nicht gecheckt die 200 waren auch schon
zweiter generation damenpaar gemeckert
in den kommentaren und das soll wohl der
absolute überschätzt sein hat mich
glaube ich irgendwie 30 euro konstant
ich muss nachschauen
die haben also auch schon ich habe dir
irgendwo im internet gefunden werden
hierfür 37 eur 61 gehandelt allerdings
meine ich sie für 31 euro gekauft zu
haben ich kommen bei diesen ganzen
airports sich da schon kopf total
durcheinander
irgendwas so wie es gewesen ist ja auch
erst mal egal und hier habe ich jetzt so
eine kleine grafik gefunden da kann man
sehen dass die 1000 tws auf jeden fall
der absolute spitzenreiter sind von
diesem modell hier keine ahnung da kommt
ja auch andauernd etwas neues heraus
kann seine es schon besser aber das sind
die kopfhörer wenn man sich die so
anschaut sind die auch ziemlich nah auf
jeden fall am original und ja
poste blofeld ja ich bin ich total aus
dem konzept gekommen wobei ihn stimmen
ich glaube ich wollte sagen wir testen
jetzt einfach um dann kann ich ja sagen
ob dies bis jetzt die besten sind oder
nicht und ob es sich lohnt die zu kaufen
auf unsere art und weise anstrengend
manchmal dieser jus student auf einen
kleinen spaß und was hier natürlich auch
wieder ganz wichtig ist zu sagen die
werden wir alle anderen auf dem
instagram account alex wie in der story
verlost ihr müsst einfach auf die
antworten und nimmt automatisch am
gewinnspiel teil dann kenne ich alle
böses wieso das ist drüber geklebt denn
da jetzt wahrscheinlich nichts drunter
kann ich nicht sagen denn erst recht ist
glaube ich ich dachte schon ich dachte
dass ich jetzt weil ich habe bei amazon
welche bestellt die habe ich so
verarscht da gibt es auch noch also
tages in der richtigen ecke aber der
händler der krieg von jahren auch noch
böse melden das sag ich immer aber mir
kommt das schon hart spanisch vor dass
das jetzt hier so drüber geklebt das
weißt du na ja gut ich will nichts sagen
hier kann man diese spiele die wollen
doch schon einmal zurück geschickt dass
wir doch nichts erzählen hier also neue
geht hier gar nichts aus naja aber sind
die airports vorne aufgeklebt oder sehe
ich das falsch
die sind nicht drauf investitionen
ja-stimmen hast recht die wurden
irgendwie so da wurde in die mit dem
stift rundherum gemalt prozent
geschichten aus spenden denn das ist die
stadt wohl irgendwie alles war ruhig und
sonstigen kram herkommen
dessen case wieso denn wieso ist dann
case bei habe ich gar nicht bestellt
es hat ja mega hatte wir machen das aber
erstmal ab jetzt nur manchmal grinst und
vor gehört also wie schon gesagt
airports kopie der zweiten generation
kann man hier hinten sehen an dem knapp
ich hab leider die originale ältere
variante deswegen lohnt es sich jetzt
nicht so richtig die zu vergleichen
ich könnte mir eigentlich demnächst mal
das ist auf jeden fall schon das jetzt
mit abstand das beste also hier merkt
man dass es hochwertig ist relativ schon
mal kurz meint also so ganz kommt so
nicht ans original audio sind wir wir
haben auf jeden fall eine proportionale
steigerung dahin sage ich mal so macht
es sinn ja hier kann man das schon mal
sehen
mehr haben wir noch nie dran glaube ich
als heute oder muss man ganz klar sagen
meinte button dieses feld was willst du
sagen das hier ist einfach zu erkennende
gut wenn man die kopfhörer aus ich bin
glücklich heute bin ich richtig gespannt
auf den sound nach das sounderlebnis gut
und was das hat dass er darin zu suchen
weil sie sind ja das kannst du hier
jetzt schlafen das finde ich auf jeden
fall gut das ist ja bei den original
nicht dabei kanzian der rucksack danke
für das case auch noch grün meine
lieblingsfarbe
da freue ich mich drüber und hier haben
wir noch das iphone kabel dazu das sieht
aber gut aus
ja das sieht aus wie ein original dass
da etwas ist erster ladekabel was
anständig aus die echten sagen die
anderen anders aus alles so heutige
kleine ladekabel soweit ist dass es ist
nicht original das merke ich schon es
der wille war da sagen wir mal so es ist
aber ganz gut nur so ein bisschen hier
filme dann merkst es gibt es geht wird
finde ich schon na ja darum geht es ja
heute nicht es geht um die airports und
werden von mir jetzt mal getestet
das sind die fakes das sind die
originalen an sich absolut gleich oder
würde ich sagen die ohrmuscheln die
ohrmuscheln
für mich sind die gleich sogar hell die
buchstaben rechts und links sind genau
gleich wirklich näher am original war
so werde ich natürlich als erstes mal
mit meinem handy connecten mal schauen
ob dort schnell geht etwas auch so ein
bisschen die schlusslichter der liste
ist da vielleicht magnet und dann ja ja
ich denke es liegt ein magnet das
gericht dann haben wir hier sogar direkt
die heißen sie sogar trotz das hat mir
vor wie diesen als sonst
die 200 tgs bieber blum airports und am
besten direkt connecten danke wo sind
wir connected ist jetzt bin ich voll
zufrieden
stell dir mal vor das sind echte werde
ich dir jetzt gleich sagen können jetzt
bin ich gleichzeitig mit 2 verbunden und
werden dennoch ins ohr steckt hast du
sogar diesen originalen apple sound
dieses zügen besser nein leute das ist
leider nicht so ich bin sonntag wenn der
wert das gleich merken ich habe einen
originalen kopfhörer mit einem fake
kopfhörer vertauscht und also ich dachte
ich spinne ich dachte ich werde
irgendwie gehackt auf china oder so mal
so komisch war zwischendurch
ich habe irgendwie nur auf dem ihr sound
komisch ja es ist komisch auf dem konto
und liegt das trennen
das ist sogar nach einer original apple
beschreibung aus da kriege ich halt das
bildlich kann hat nichts davon lesen
chinesisch dieser ich habe hier gegen
die musik drauf von irgendwo hast du das
einfach wurden ja hast du gemacht hast
du irgendwelche blut wie koks regel
video connect ist weiß ich auch nicht in
meinen rhythmus aus aber wieso will kann
sie dann mit einem kopfhörer connected
sein und ich nicht also wieso ist sie
mit dem ein connector nicht mit dem
anderen leute irgendwie ist das komisch
der deklariert hier den rechten immer
als kaputt oder so ihr könnt ja sehr
gern meine kommentare schreiben
woran das liegt das einzige was ich als
marc rath ist halt mit dem linken höher
und das habe ich natürlich auch schon
öfter mal gemacht dreht man ja also
soundqualität ist so ok ist okay aber
noch tatsächlich nicht so gut also ich
weiß nicht so ganz was ich dazu sagen
soll muss ich ehrlich sein wir haben
jetzt verbindet er ab weil diese chance
ja ich warum geht das nicht ein gewehr
wenn es nicht geht kann dann morgen
leute kurzhaarkatzen kurzer nachtrag und
zwar das video hier habe ich eigentlich
schon und juri vorgestern aufgenommen
und ich bin gestern abend in die bahn
gestiegen mit meinen airports wir hatten
ja das problem dass hier der eine
kopfhörer nicht funktioniert hat und
dann wollte ich musik hören und mir ist
aufgefallen scheiße hier jetzt ja auch
nicht das heißt ich habe die während ich
die euch gezeigt habe vertauscht und
musste jetzt halt noch mal tauschen und
dann geht es auf hoffentlich also da
haben wir das problem gelöst und ich
kann einmal den vollen wo sind jetzt war
durcheinander mit den ganzen also das
sind jetzt die beiden richtigen
kopfhörer und die muss jetzt mit einem
handy connect und dann kann ich noch
einmal das bundesamt erlebnis sage ich
mal erleben und euch meine meinung dazu
sagen wir haben es gleich kann sich noch
so jetzt bin ich verbunden
[Musik]
also an reicht eigentlich auch schon wir
hatten ja beim vorgestern nur den linken
jeweils drin also der rechte hat halt
nicht funktioniert war der nicht
dazugehört mal und vom sound her kann
ich aber weiterhin sagen dass es bis
jetzt auf jeden fall die beste kopiert
werden doch nichts besseres ich weiß
nicht es sind auf jeden fall schon
wieder neue modelle rauskommen die ich
in zukunft auch testen werde und
eventuell habt ihr ja auch noch tipps wo
ich mal nach airport kopien schauen
können in irgendwelchen supermärkten
oder sonst was also wenn ihr da
irgendwas selbst du mir gerne ich kaufe
das dann mal ein ansonsten war's das
jetzt wird im video das ist jetzt gerade
ein bisschen schwierig weil ich das eine
video ist eigentlich schon fertig ist
mit diesem hier jetzt so ein bisschen
vermisse aber ich sag ja immer da ich
mit dem produkt an sich selber nichts
anfangen kann
ja ja das klappt alles wie immer auch im
instagram account ihr müsst einfach nur
keystone die antworten in der ich das
produkt dann posten werde und wir sehen
uns morgen um 19 uhr wieder gibt es ein
neues video ich hoffe es hat euch
trotzdem gefallen und zwar jetzt ein
bisschen chaotisch ja aber nicht den
kanal locker aktivieren und weil ich so
nett bin kriegt der gewinner dann auch
noch dieses wunderschöne grüne case dazu
das komischerweise dabei war und wir
haben auch noch was eine schnelle dann
kann man das halt irgendwie man kann man
es halt hier am hosenbund befestigen
ob man das braucht weiß ich nicht aber
sieht ja ganz teile fürs und also heute
haut rein